not just Islam but stop demonizing any
group we are living in a time and we are
living in a culture that loves to hate
or needs to hate okay I mean as long as
I have been alive and for a lot of time
before the West or the developed
countries has always been demonizing a
group I mean if it wasn't like the only
good Indian as a dead Indian
you know you you you come forward into
world war two where you know the Germans
were Krauts and then the you know the
Korean War with where the Koreans were
the gooks and then into the Vietnamese
war where the you know they weren't
Vietnamese no no they were Charlie or
slants or something like this you know
and you know every different person is
given a name that is dehumanizing them
okay you're not you know you're not
killing you know you're not killing a
person you're killing a kraut World War
two you know you're you know you're not
killing a North Korean you're killing a
[ __ ] you know it's you know an ugly word
you know you're not you're not killing a
Vietnamese you're killing a slant well
what does this ugliness come from but
this is it's a process of basically
programming a people to see another
people as as something different from
what they are and every single time
every single time after the massacre
you know after the dust settles we turn
around and we start realizing that we're
rubbing shoulders with these people and
they're okay you know the Indians that
we massacred the American Indians that
we massacred we now go and visit their
revenue and their reservations we enjoy
their art we enjoy their food we see the
beauty of their customs and the
gentleness of their natures after World
War two the you know there are all these
touching stories of soldiers who were
united with their counterparts you know
and the the American you know the
American soldier who was interned in a
prison of war
and suffered horribly during his
internment and death uh and later after
the war is United with his captors and
they both just realized we were we were
on different sides of the equation and
we're both ok you know or the one who
was shot down by another pilot or he you
know was you know intimately involved in
the struggle of life and death in the
struggle of the war against another
counterpart with which they were United
later and you know later and they just
realized you know I mean we're all human
mm-hmm
you know I mean the Germans in this
country the Japanese in this country
where'd they come from the same
countries that we were fighting and what
do we think about them now uh-huh
I mean sushi you know I mean everybody
knows knows a Japanese person if nothing
else just from our food culture and and
you know we we found that the people
that we were killing before we found
that the people that we were fighting
before on the basis of ideology who we
thought were less than human they're
okay yeah after the Vietnam War I mean
you couldn't go into a convenience store
in America except you had a high chance
that you're gonna be different doing
business with the Vietnamese mm-hmm and
and they were okay and what a shock of
shocks you know I mean they're just like
us they do they just want to live life
and and you know have a peaceful
existence and so on and so forth that's
the the power of the human connection
I'm just saying look I'm just saying
whether you're talking about the you
know the forces that we were at war with
in World War two what you're talking
about
you know Mussolini's Italy and you know
in that period or whether you're talking
about the you know the Nazi Germans or
whether you're talking about the
Japanese I'm talking about the you know
Koreans during the Korean War the
Vietnamese it it just doesn't matter
what pool you look at I mean once you
started once these people were conquered
and we found ourselves you know they
immigrated and we found ourselves living
next to them
we found all of our preconceptions
dispelled we found that we had been lied
to
we found that we had been deceived and
we found that it was all for the purpose
of an agenda that was beyond us okay so
when are we gonna wake up when are when
are we gonna open our minds and
recognize that we are being misled for a
purpose for an agenda good points more
to come with dr. Lawrence Brown here in
the Dean shot to anywhere